I'll tell you what was an interesting
experience uh I I just shot a movie I'm
allowed to talk about it on fire the
director ended up getting coid and uh
and I ended up having to take over
directing it unbelievable and uh you
produced it you co-directed it yeah yeah
and started it and started it well I
originally was just going to start in it
right you know they were like hey this
this movie do you want to come out and
and I thought this is a good premise and
and you there's a lot of fires in the
world right now and this is this movie
kind of shows you what people go through
you know and uh and so I like that
aspect of it and I wasn't a producer on
it either like until I came on and then
there were things that they were like
hey would you produce it cuz there's
things that we could use your help on I
was like okay and then the director got
sick and then I they were like hey would
you just take over for
tonight and then they were like we can't
shut down we just finished I was like
yeah and then when then it was good cuz
when I was in post and I was able to
like have more say which is always great
cuz as an actor more fun more creative
yeah it's more creative and and so many
times as an actor I'm sure you know too
like we give over our work and we think
oh that I feel like this is going to be
a good one and then you get disappointed
because uh you don't have any say in
like the the the rhythm of the movie or
how they uh how they put it together or
your performance and you're like I know
I gave them better stuff than that you
know what I mean so like when I saw the
cut you know I was able to say well let
let's try this or let's these
performances can be better and you know
get jumped into the editing room and
shaped it and you know the whole ending
we reshot because the original ending
just didn't feel it felt like it fell
flat you know so uh so this ending that
you saw was completely give yeah uh
completely reshot and then became more
of a tribute to Firefighters and First
Responders that whole sequence wasn't in
there you know through the woods thing
yeah the keep running uh and that kid
had no you know that who played my son
he didn't have any Arc so I was like we
need an arc for so I was able to get way
more input into that because I I was now
directing and producing um so it's
called onire it's available on video on
demand digital release film November
14th November 14 so it's going to be
right around here guys so you got to
check this out because what I and
continue but I just wanted to say that
what I liked about it is that the
characters were all really well thought
out it wasn't like I mean you
immediately care about them you got this
old man your father played by Lance
Hendrickson who I love I met just a
legend and like it's not just this you
know angry old guy it's like this
emotional guy who just wants to be with
his wife who passed away and like the
some of those scenes are so emotional he
just wants to smoke and says screw it
this is my life let me just you know let
me go and this whole time you're trying
to hang on to him you're trying to and
you know and the and the and your wife
is in the movie is so
she's great and she's so strong she's
pregnant and she's the strong character
so all the characters are really strong
or develop and I and I and I saw that
and I liked the even the CGI with the
fires I was like I was looking and it
looked really good yeah cuz when I
started that when I came on when I got
this Set uh Nick Nick lion who who who
directed it alongside with me he started
out as the main director and he when I
came on he were like oh we're not using
any fire you know at all we're going to
do all CGI and I thought oh this better
be good or it's going to be bad yeah
yeah yeah uh so so then when we got into
the editing room you know we had this uh
this great um CGI artist uh Joe Lawson
and we just kept pushing him you know
he' come back with stuff it's still
little keep going back had shapes shades
of and he did such a great job like now
we have like stock footage stuff and we
have uh CGI Stu I can't tell the
difference sometimes which one is real
and which one just like the smoke only
when you're driving the smoke go in and
out of stuff that was really cool thank
you so so when I took over as director
for that it was interesting because you
know when when I'm an actor there's a
part of me that really wants to please
the director all the time because you're
there to service their stories so like
you know you finish a take and you're
always immediately like look to them
like not of approval do they like it am
I way off like did you know is it too
big too small and uh and you know you
and I have been doing this for a long
time so there's part of us that knows
like what feels right what doesn't but
but you always are looking straight to
that director and catching their eye and
they're like thumbs up and you know can
I try it different like what else could
I do what else do you think uh and so
what was interesting is I've directed
before uh other actors I love actors I
love like working with them and I love
collaborating with them and I love
because they're it's such a vulnerable
place like like you just mentioned like
when knowing your lines and the pressure
so getting actors to go look you know
let's just play you know and and find
stuff together and like I think that's
appreciated and when I work with
directors that are actors like they
understand that that lingo because
sometimes you get directors that are
just like why you making that face or
you're like what face don't do that slow
down faster yeah faster moving on yeah
and you're just like and it's like cold
bedside manner you know so I think that
actors appreciate when I work with them
because I see everything you know every
little thing an eye movement I'm like I
I saw what you do actors need to be
acknowledged for what they're doing like
sometimes coddled sometimes they
different actors need different things
but sometimes you have to be that
director comes and goes hey you were
that was really good I really liked what
you did let's do something else now
because we got that it's awesome yeah
even if it was terrible you're like it's
good to tell them it because then
they're like okay good I got one on and
then they loosen up like a loose actor
is a good actor